[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.
How you doing, sir?
You're a Muslim, obviously. Do you
believe the Quran converts the Bible?
No. All right.
Just trying to get a conversation with
EM.
What's up, brother? You Muslim?
you. Oh, we we're saying that the Quran
confirms the Bible. What you think about
that?
Yeah. No. Okay, cool. Yeah. You think
it's all in line together? Well, in
terms of the Quran and the beliefs of
the Bible, I think so. Yeah. Okay. So,
so I'm a Christian myself. Okay. Okay.
Yeah. Um I' I've read the entire Quran,
about 95% of it. My biggest thing is
about how the what the Quran says about
the Bible. It talks about how the Quran
came confirming previous scriptures. um
how it came like it's in line with them.
This is how Jews and Christians can see
that Muhammad's a prophet, right? Um so
this is really huge for me as a
Christian, right? Um the problem that I
have is though is that when I when I
check the previous interrupt,
but maybe the Bible confirms the Quran.
You got it backwards.
Are you a Christian? Yes. Yeah, I'm I'm
a Christian as well. Yeah, I can tell.
It's that it's that life force we have.
That's right. That's right. And you're
out here working hard. Thank you,
sister. Let me finish. All things
truthful. That's right. God bless you,
sister. God bless you. So, so basically,
when I So, when the Quran confirms the
inje
kind of they teach different things,
right? Obviously, there's Jesus's Lord,
crucifixion. What are what are your
thoughts on that? How like how is that
reconciled? if like as a Christian it's
like okay you know what the Quran says
the Bible's good but I see that there's
different beliefs what do you think I
think in terms of uh the Quran as well
they take in terms of like let's just
say you know how in hide park and
everything they have those whole
speakers quarters and everything they
take a lot of things out of context when
it comes to the Quran as well so like
one common one as well like when they
talk about how um the killing of other
people how it's allowed in Islam and
everything which has been completely
taken out of context But the the Quran
like Allah instructed us that in in the
face of defense for us to protect
ourselves then we can go into battle and
kill. But it's to kill for the it's
clearly says in the for the sake of God
to kill for the sake of God to strive in
the sake of God in the name of God to
protect God. But people have completely
blown that out context and you know how
in the western society or how everyone
just blows out the fact that you know
how there's ISIS and terrorist groups
and everything radical groups. Yeah.
Yeah. So um for that I believe
personally I think it's western funded
all these groups. Interesting. I feel
like ISIS groups and everything they're
all western funding. All right. So let
me let me ask you then cuz I I got a
Quran. I'll get your interpretation on
this verse here. Um it's it's a pretty
popular verse that people bring up when
it talks about um it's kind of like
after Muhammad basically conquered
Arabia, you know, he beat all his
enemies who were breaking treaties and
stuff, right? But then we get to uh
surah 9. Saratoba
verse 29 and it says uh it says this
here. So it says fight against those who
believe not in Allah nor in the last day
nor forbid that which has been forbidden
by Allah and his messenger uh and those
who acknowledge not the religion of
truth among the people of the scripture
right the Jews and Christians until they
pay their Jiza with willing submission
and feel themselves subdued. Right? So
from my understanding if we read earlier
I can see like like verses 1 to5 there's
a treaty with like the polytheists and
if the treaty if they break their treaty
then the Muslims are able to fight back
or whatever right you know this right
here though begins to talk about
fighting the Jews and Christians because
of what they believe not for them
oppressing the Muslims how would you
interpret this well the thing is um I'm
not really fully studied within that's
what I'm saying I appreciate the the
humility of course But like cuz I got
caugh I got put on the spot guys but you
know it is um all I can say you know
what it is for me the the thing is I
feel like in terms of Christians as well
we all believe in this one God right but
uh when it comes to like the the
diversion when it comes in that bit is
the scriptures yes scriptures the old
testament the new testament yes um and I
feel like that has a big impact on how
Muslims view Christians and other but in
terms of the the can I just read the
yeah yeah sure it was uh this verse
right here.
[Music]
Yeah.
To be honest with you, I'm not really
even that interested in talking about
this. I I would rather talk about what
you just said, how the view on the Old
Testament, New Testament, and um just as
a Muslim, how you would how how that
affects your view on the Bible or you
know, everything. Do you know what? I'll
be honest with you. Um I mean that's
yours. But um aside from this in terms
of as a Christian brother, I'll be
honest with you, bro. We have very
similar beliefs. We do. All of us have
very similar beliefs. We do. You believe
in God. We believe in the prophets.
Exactly. You guys believe in the
prophets. We believe in the prophets.
You know what I'm saying? You guys have
different names for it. Simple. That's
how it is. But the way that people
interpret it, right? Um in both, let's
say, Muslims and Christians, there is a
bit of a there is a bit of a struggle
there in terms of communication and
everything. But I personally like I have
lots of respect for you.
You know, you know what I mean? Like
your beliefs and everything%
definitely there are a few differences
and stuff but that is something that of
course um when talked about throughout
the Quran like if you actually go
through the Quran and the Bible at the
same time we can analyze that is said
but it's said in different formats. So
this is this is where because I I agree
with you like that on on the on the
surface we have a lot of uh places that
we can agree on. Uh excuse me brother,
we got like um um we believe in God, one
God. We believe in the prophets, right?
We believe that God sent revelation
through messengers, right? And
scripture. Um the part that we disagree
on are core issues like on who go is God
a trinity? Is he absolutely singular in
his essence? Um is Jes did God come in
the flesh and die for our sins or not?
is that way you know beyond for you know
basically below for God to do and really
this is like uh in the Quran it's like
this it says that the Christians say
that Jesus the Messiah is a son of Allah
right they are disbelievers they're
imitating disbelievers from before them
and Allah's curses on them whoever are
saying this Christians obviously in the
Bible it says that Jesus is the son of
God and God sent his son into the world
to save it so it's either you believe
Jesus is the son of God and receive salv
ation based on the gospel or from the
Quran if you say Jesus is the son of God
you're going to hell because that's
basically sherk that's associating a
part with the law right so these are
salvation heaven and hell issues that we
disagree on like it's core it's really
important so for me it's like this the
conundrum I have is like when I read the
Quran like my favorite verse of the
Quran is chapter 5:47 surah 47 it says
let the people of the gospel judge by
what Allah has revealed in it. And
whoever does not judge by what Allah has
revealed, they're the wrongdoers. So I'm
like, "Okay, cool. I'm a person of the
gospel. Since I believe Oh, hey.
Since I believe in the gospel, I have to
judge by it from what the Quran says.
Now, when I read the gospel, I see that
Jesus came and was crucified. I see that
Jesus is the son of God. So I have to
judge by that. Now, when I read the
Quran, it says the opposite. So if I'm
judging by the gospel, I have to judge
that the Quran is false. there's no
reconciliation for that. You know,
that's that's my position. You know, if
you want to share your thoughts on that,
I'd love to hear it. Um um I just want
to ask one question. Like I know I know
you guys believe that of course Mary
gave birth to Jesus, right? Yeah. As a
virgin. And as a virgin. Okay. So, but
you guys believe Jesus is God. Like this
is just my I'm still confused on Yeah,
you you can ask whatever you want,
brother. Ask whatever you want. So um
how can Jesus be God but can be given
birth by Mary if you get what? Yeah, of
course. Of course. So the the the
Christian belief is that it's called the
incarnation basically. So you have Jesus
who existed as God in the form of God
but then also takes on a human nature.
He takes on a human nature and is born
through a woman. So it's not that he
stops being God or loses his divine
attributes, but he just takes on a human
nature to himself. So we believe that
God he's all powerful. He can he can
come in whatever form he chooses to. And
so this is what we believe that he did
in that way. Yeah. Oh, that's fine. All
right. Yeah. Um do you do you believe
that God if he wanted to that he could
do that? The thing is the you know God
is almighty. He can do whatever he
wants. You know what I'm saying? the the
core belief that God came into a form of
a human and then died on the on the
cross. Yeah. That is something which God
can never die. You know what I'm saying?
God was of course if so to be to like
what what's your understanding of death?
What what do you think death is? So for
me in my religion in terms of after we
pass away we go into the afterlife where
there's a waiting period called the bara
where we get judged and everything
within the grave. So the three questions
as well who is your lord who is who
they'll show a picture of the prophet
who is this and what is your religion
that's something that we ask but it's
something that we cannot physically say
unless our belief was actually correct
in the first place won't move unless we
actually acted upon those understood so
so death basically is it's not ceasing
to exist but it's moving on to the
afterlife right and so um and that's
what that's what death is in my religion
as well it's separation of the soul and
the body. And so obviously with God, he
doesn't have a body. He's not a human.
He doesn't have a body that that he
lives in or possesses. And so um the
only way he can experience death is if
he took on a a human body and then
separated from that. And that's what we
believe that he did. So we don't believe
that God when he died on the cross um in
his human form that he ceased to exist
or stopped ruling the universe. He's all
powerful. So that can never happen, you
know. Um even Jesus says something very
interesting. He says, "No one takes my
life from me. I lay it down myself. And
I have the authority to lay it down, and
I have the authority to pick it back up
again." So Jesus is saying, "Death can't
hold me." So even though I lay down my
life, it can't hold me. I'm going rise
again. So So when um I just wanted to
ask like, you can ask what whatever you
want, bro. Ask whatever you want. You
know, in the Bible, I've heard the when
Jesus prostrated on the floor. Um I
don't know where about you know what I
actually feel quite embarrassed. the
fact, you know, it is like I feel like I
need to go home and I need to study more
after definitely 100% I need to study
more. Um because don't get me wrong,
I've never had these sort of
conversations, but it's nice to see like
the comparison as well with the both
religions. There's a lot of similarity
as well. A lot of similarity. So, it's
quite nice. I quite like that. Yeah.
Yeah. I enjoy this. I definitely need to
I need to go back home and study both.
But yeah, if you could just tell me
about the fact where Jesus Jesus is
praying to the father on the floor, you
know, uh yeah. So what's what's the
what's the story with that? What's Yeah,
for sure. So what's going on is is that
this is happening right before Jesus is
about to take on the sins of the world
and is um he's feeling all the sorrow,
all the grief, all the cares being upon
him, right? So he's praying to to the
father. Now to to get this straight, we
believe in what is called the trinity.
Right? So we believe that God in his
infinite essence, he exists as three
distinct persons. You have the father,
you have the son Jesus Christ, and you
have the holy spirit. Okay. Um it's
okay. You guys can go ahead. Go ahead.
It's okay.
So um so yeah. So you have the father,
son, holy spirit, right? So from
eternity's past, they've communed with
each other. They've been in constant
fellowship. So when Jesus comes on the
earth and is praying to the father,
prayer is just communication with the
divine. So the son communicating to the
father um and and in that moment, you
know, he is a humble servant to the
father. He submits to the father, right?
That's his role. He takes the role of a
servant, right? Um but that doesn't take
away from his divine nature, right? Like
for example, um I don't know if you do
you work, you have a boss over you.
Yeah, you got a boss. All right. So you
got a boss over you. you submit to your
boss. You're the servant of your boss,
right? But that doesn't mean that he's
more human than you are or she, right?
So you guys have the same nature. So
it's the same thing with Christ. Christ
and the father, they have the same
divine nature, but Christ takes a humble
role to the father and acts as his
servant. Okay? So that's what we see. We
see that demonstrated in the when he's
prostrating. You know what I'm saying?
Um we see that a lot. We also see him
display his authority though, right? We
see him say things like um whoever comes
to me will have eternal life. He says
I'm the only way, the truth, and the
life. No one comes to the father except
through me. You know, he says, "I will
give you eternal life, and on the last
day, at the last hour, I'm going to
judge and raise you up." Like, what in
the world? You can't be saying that if
you're a good prophet. You know what I'm
saying? He says things that would damn
him to hell for blasphemy if he's not
who he really is, which is God in the
flesh, you know? So, yep. No, I respect
that, bro. Yeah. Yeah, for sure. If you,
brother, uh, I I do this often, man. Um,
I'm I'm on Instagram as God Logic.
That's my Instagram. Yeah. On Instagram.
Yeah. Yep. On Instagram. And so, you
could DM me, man. Cuz I I you know, I
want to we could continue. All right. We
could stay connected, man, cuz you you
gave me, you know, ask good questions.
So, want to be You guys can go ahead. I
know. No, it's definitely I feel like I
do need to learn a lot more but um
understanding from today as well there
is a lot of similarities and stuff.
There's a lot of respect for you guys as
well. For sure. For sure. Yeah. Um but
for us of course uh what what your takes
on believing in the prophet Muhammad.
Yeah. So my bit like I said my biggest
thing is is this right here is how is
what the Quran says about the Bible. So
like for example you have uh in chapter
61:6 it says that Jesus mentioned a
messenger to come after him named Amed
right you have chapter 7 verse 157 that
says those who follow the unlettered
prophet who they can find written in the
Torah and gospel with them you know who
enjoins good upon them and all this kind
of stuff. So the big claim in the Quran
is that I as a Christian, as a person of
the book, can find Muhammad's
description in my book. And so
therefore, I should be able to believe
in him. That's my biggest thing. So if I
can if I can find him in there, I'd
believe in him. I I trust him as a
messenger cuz I I follow the scriptures.
If he's not in there, then these are
false claims, right? And so, um,
obviously with my studies, I haven't
seen Muhammad's description. And I've
I've heard arguments and at closer look
at them, it it doesn't pan out in their
context. You know, some Muslim will pick
out a verse, but in his context, it has
nothing to do with Muhammad. I'm like,
where are you getting this stuff from,
you know? So, I don't believe that he's
a true prophet because he doesn't meet
those claims that the Quran says I can
find, you know. So, that's the biggest
thing for me. Yeah. I hope that makes
sense. No, you know, I respect that,
bro. Yeah. Um, I respect that.
Definitely. I'll keep in touch with you.
Yeah, man. And yeah, bro. You always
nice. It's a pleasure. Yeah, it's a
pleasure. Yeah, man. Keep doing your
thing. May God bless. You, too, man.
Yeah. Yeah. I appreciate the good
conversation, man. So, be safe for the
rest of your day. God bless you, bro.
All right. Take care.
It's God. It's God. It's God.
Is God the